[Music]
hey
what are you there
yeah i'm just here i'm very very close
to your earhole just got this new webcam
now you're you're the kind of tech guy
out there
um
just checking the webcams working they
said you have to be right in the center
of the frame how is it good hey could
you take one step back
one more step back
one more step back
one more step back
you look fantastic dom
have you had a haircut have you had a
haircut
i got a haircut today what do you think
we're calling it military punk i love it
and might i see
that is a fine mustache
well thank you we're gonna get into the
mustache and the reason why i have the
mustache in a second but i know you're
in the middle of a job right now so you
don't have the freedom of haircuts but i
would say
when you get out of
this uh job responsibility yeah maybe we
can do haircut twins because i think you
could rock this haircut amazingly
i'd love my hair to look like that but
at the moment um i'm in sort of 19th
century north america so
i thirst my hair thusly
forward the hair people do that in the
mornings right
what do you think
quite quite quite kind of null gallagher
lean gallagher-esque
how does it how does it feel to be in
that period of history you can't really
reveal a huge amount about what you what
you're doing but you you play quite a
dastardly character don't you yeah he's
not the nicest guy to be honest um and
at that time there was there was a lot
of people who were not very nice like
that and and what's really concerning
there's still some people these days
that are not very nice like that yeah
treating human beings not like human
beings yeah
are you still in a place because we in
in our industry we we have times where
we can and can't reveal stuff are you
still in a place where you can't
necessarily say what this job is that
you're doing i think i can see that it
is washington black
so it is uh based on that novel that
wonderful noise
brilliant and then which you've read
haven't you
my
second favorite book that i read last
year i read um two books very fast on
set last year the first one was called
all the light we cannot see which is a
beautiful a beautiful book uh about um
two young kids going through the second
world war and then the second one bought
for me by my amazing makeup eyes
uh aisling duffy was
washington black and i was charmed by it
the whole world beautiful and what a
great character washington black
lovely and the
the actors playing washington black
because there is more than one as it
goes through quite a lot of time
are both wonderful beautiful young
actors and they're both both great so uh
i'm very much looking forward to seeing
this one dom and it's been great fun and
i'm up in them nova scotia
new scotland
new scotland and you've been very
impressed by nova scotia i've never been
but you recommend it highly don't you
yeah i've been here a few times now and
the last time i was here
just outside halifax there's a place
called dartmouth and this is one of my
favorite t-shirts look at this though
dramath is pretty nice
that's quite canadian isn't it
pretty nice really nice pretty good
let's not go too much here
i love it it's a lovely place dom you'd
love it i can't wait to see i know it's
i know it's kind of a place of the great
outdoors and and can get a little cold
in the winter and stuff but from a
culinary point of view
what is it that nova scotia
do
better than anywhere else are they
really good for a certain type of wine
or a fish dish or
seafood dump yeah i'll see they love
their seafood
they love it here and it's absolutely
delicious and if there was one
one thing that i think we all try to
find and if you go to a new part of town
or you go to a new little village or
whatever
a lobster roll
everyone seems to
that's where you get the best lobster
roll they'll say so that's how you you
pick a good restaurant or a bad one and
a lobster roll is delicious
it's like it's it's almost like uh
a roll of lobster
no it's like lobster and some bread but
the bread is normally like toasted with
butter
and then oh dom with some lemon on it
[Laughter]
and you'll hear that up and down the
streets of halifax
[Laughter]
um
and uh you recently had covered william
recently had covered dom i did i
received that in my body somehow and
uh i had to go and quarantine
for
eight days
i found myself dumb i found myself right
but then i lost myself again
i actually it was good the production
oh you'll get covered get out yeah got
me in a little a little cottage next to
a lake
maybe like remember that movie misery
sort of like that
but without anybody there breaking my
ankles of that which was good
so
and it was actually quite nice i just
kind of it was the weather was quite
nice i didn't feel too bad a couple of
days
of our lives
uh
quite a lot of league of legends
yes quite a lot of league of legends i
read quite a lot
and then
listen to music it was actually all
right you seemed you seemed to exhibit
very similar symptoms to my dad which
was a little bit of a dry scratchy
throat kind of
and slightly under the weather but kind
of hard to define how you're under the
weather just a bit kind of
yeah just a bit
but then when i came back and i did my
first day's work
i got in the car to come back to the
hotel and i thought i'm gonna go for
dinner tonight looking forward to it
and when i got to the hotel
not an ounce of energy did i have oh
i couldn't have went for dinner i didn't
have the energy
to make my jaw open and close yeah in a
queueing manner
so i just i went straight to bed i was
exhausted it takes out you it does take
it out did you ask did you call the
production and ask for possibly an ad to
come over and while you were taking
small inhalations in while you were
breathing just drop little pieces of
lobster roll into your mouth
that would be lovely
you know you could joke and die perhaps
but yeah you could yeah i couldn't i
couldn't get out that night but i'm
feeling i'm feeling pretty much 100
again
two things i like to i like to um use
numbers in a in a slightly unorthodox
way because normally i would do that
peace but i'm doing that which is which
is a fun one two things billy first of
all yes we did play league of legends
you ended up playing really good league
of legends while you had covered so
maybe you should consider having covert
again because you were quite good at
league of legends doing that but
one of one of the slight one of the
things that i'm happy that you've left
behind now is during league of legends
while you had covered you you were still
having that throaty thing and every so
often when we were playing in different
parts of the map you would go
and i was like oh my god what's going on
with billy and i was like ah that's
right he's got cove and he's got it but
it was it was terrifying every time he
did it
that was very very kind of you dumb not
to bring that up
when we were playing that could have
made me feel better but uh yeah no it
was good it was a lot of good games
during that time it was fun yeah you
were playing excellent at legalizing and
then the second thing number two
is that um i remember when you actually
did start to feel fully human you took
yourself down for a slap up seafood meal
and you took pictures of it and
everything scallops and oysters and oh
my god
my god that was love that was like my
second day out wasn't it and i just i
thought i'm gonna get a lunch
and a i saw this place i suppose we were
in a little town called um
he's not frozen he's just thinking
he forgot the name of it but it might
come back to me and it's just starting
to open up for the season you know so
little restaurants would open up
sort of every couple of days or whatever
and i saw this place and it was
fantastic and i thought i need to send
this to the boys
being their hobbits
because as we know dom and this was your
idea
uh as we're doing this little tour of
conventions um this year and
first time ever that all four hobbits
have have done that
dom had the idea that we whatever city
we're in
dallas whatever orlando that we go to a
nice restaurant and we have a nice
evening together and we've been doing
that and that's what made me think when
i went there and i got these lovely
oysters i thought i'm going to send a
picture to the boys you see what they
think of this
yeah yeah it was a lovely because i had
been in the house having tins of soup
and stuff for eight days it was nice to
kind of splurge out a little bit
peeling the onion
i think we we might have time for one
housekeeping thing especially since
uh this is in regards to the tap paradox
or the farsec paradox that we talked
about last week so
i'm going to read this out go on this is
from this is from a youtube user whose
name is another postcard
that's what their name is on youtube
says
to answer dom's question the answer is
surface tension each separate little
body of water has this thing called
surface tension that in a way acts as a
barrier to the world outside the drop
when that barrier is touched by another
one they merge together and then they
continue i suspect that there are tiny
drops of water present or the drops
themselves are elongated
enough that their respective surfaces
are merging and that merge goes all the
way up into the faucet or tap this
creates a cylindrical column of flowing
water molecules aka
otherwise known as dom's continuous
stream of water this is called laminar
flow and it's all due to the surface
tension of the water this is used to
great effect in the animated film a
bug's life thank you another postcard
well that that was that was wonderful it
was succinct
yeah there's everything we needed to
know dom yeah and it's just solidified
your genius in some ways
yes i think so now
i don't know we might should we do one
more
come on tom
regarding
spooky movies this is from deborah on
youtube
yeah she asks what is the scariest movie
that came from the 1970s they were less
graphic leaving more to the imagination
i think they work better that way first
of all for her is the exorcist
second is black christmas third is the
sentinel i've not seen black christmas
or the sentinel
oh my exorcist is scary though
exorcist is the scariest film in the 70s
for me and then is is rosemary's baby
from the 70s
i would think or is it though yeah i
think and what was the was the one with
them
well this is going to be welcome to my
world of the vague i'm afraid here
see if you can get this one
it's got an actor in it
yeah is it don't look now
is it a a girl with a red dress a red
jacket
yeah points points on the board yeah
donald sutherland julie christie
girl drowns they go to venice terrified
how did i know
we've never really spoke about that film
wow did you know
um i i don't know sometimes you just
know really
hiring right now is hard no one is more
committed to helping businesses than
indeed that's why they're giving away 50
million dollars in indeed sponsorship
job credits to help businesses like
yours hire great people fast in the
minute i've been talking to you and
billy's been talking to you 16 hires
were made on indeed according to indeed
data worldwide when you sponsor an
indeed post in the us you're three times
more likely to get a higher according to
indeed data right candidate is doing
everything they can to find you and if
you use indeed you can be sure you're
doing everything you can to find them
too finding great talent doesn't have to
be a second job you can hire faster and
better with indeed
dom as you know
indeed makes it super easy because
everything happens in one place virtual
interviews that saves you time you can
message schedule interview top talent
seamlessly all in one place indeed saves
you headaches interview virtually no
downloads plugins or purchases you can
do it all in one place with indeed even
better indeed's the only job site where
you only play for applications that meet
your must-have requirements indeed is an
unbelievably powerful hiring partner
delivering four times more hires than
all other job sites combined according
to talent nest 2019 join more than three
million businesses worldwide that use
indeed to hire great talent fast
sign up for indeed now and get 75
dollars credit towards your first
sponsored job plus earn up to 500 extra
in sponsorship job credits with indeed's
virtual interviews visit indeed.com
onion to learn more claim your credits
at indeed.com
onion indeed.com
onion terms and conditions apply need to
hire you need indeed
sweaty sac summer is approaching and
it's time for you to prioritize the
comfort of your crotch
that's why the kings of crotch comfort
manscaped have spent two years designing
the most comfortable boxer briefs out
there now
i have had the honor of testing out
these new boxers and i can tell you that
they have the softest fabric of any
underwear
they are incredibly breathable so so
comfortable fantastic
you know manscaped i've even trademarked
the dual pouch so you know that they're
serious about it
i think it's time for you to invest in
your family duels
so
just let everything breathe down there
and get 20 off plus free shipping by
using the code onion at manscape.com i
very much enjoyed their lawnmower 4.0
the best electric trimmer for below the
waist grooming this trimmer offers skin
safe technology designed to trim hair on
loose skin
also the tagless waistband of the boxer
shorts hugs your body without digging in
and it lays flat against your skin to
reduce chafing there's a front fly that
gives easy access and makes bathroom
breaks quick and efficient and you can
choose from an arrangement of designs
and colors and sizes from small to three
times extra large for all you guys out
there get 20 off and free shipping with
the code onionmanscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with the
code onion at manscape.com once you try
the new boxers 2.0
you'll never go back
we're going to do the guess but i want
to talk about the mustache because it
links to the guest were you going to
talk about the guest
i was going to i was going to talk about
a guest and also
why i'm not involved with the guest
no i mean not involved
i'm not involved in the interview
because
you did a fantastic job
i hope you don't mind me seeing like
like a young terry wagon
oh thanks yeah what a parky a parkinson
at the top of his game
yeah no
an old guest this week is perry
pinkhurst
who is
a fighter pilot
now why would we have a fighter pilot on
at this time
the answer is the film top gun maverick
which you recently saw and i recently
saw and you
really really had an enjoyable time in
the cinema just talk us through that a
little bit
don't
it's
i loved it i cannot tell you how much i
loved it because the number would be too
high
it was the weirdest experience i've ever
had at a cinema as well
why sat down here i'll tell you my dog i
sat down and the first sort of scene
started right
and it's
maverick
it's got all these friends
and they're all i don't want to waste or
spoil the film but this is the first 10
minutes 15 minutes we're talking about
here
he is in a program where they'll get
this new fighter plane that they want to
get to mach 10
which is 10 times the speed of sound wow
mach 10
and
if you remember the dialogue this is all
guys who have been working together for
years on this the dialogue was the main
guy
saying
right
they're going to cancel this if we don't
get to mac 10
yeah
now we don't have to get to 10.1 but we
have to get it and i was just thinking
everybody in this room knows that you do
not have to say that this is just
exposition which is you know and it's
not great for a script yeah just people
who already have information telling the
information to the audience so i was
ready to switch off to them
i thought no no i'm not going to buy
this
maverick got in that plane
nobody thought he was going to get to 10
nobody thought it they were only even
going to go for nine that day and he
just pushed up he pushed the handle and
it got to 10.
and then dumb he didn't pull it back he
went
10.1 and the main guy who told us they
had to get to 10 he went oh see that
maverick he didn't say that but he said
it in his eyes yeah and in that maverick
it pushed 10.2 the whole thing's gone at
10.3 i was like ammon i am a hundred
percent in this movie and from that
movement that moment on to him
i loved it i sat in that chair myself
and
i was i was weeping at parks i was
cheering i absolutely loved it
yeah you sent a message again to the
hobbits saying that you couldn't
remember a time where you enjoyed a film
as much in the cinema
and you've been waxing lyrical about it
since it is it's an incredible popcorn
movie it gives you everything that you
want and shamelessly just kind of says
we we're just we're just going to throw
everything at you the kitchen sink we
don't care we love fighter planes we
love tom cruise as maverick we're going
to give you everything
exactly and and not in a sort of
subtext way it's just all
just saying look we're doing this now
because we want you to cry at this point
and i'm like i can see you doing that
and i'm crying at this point
i don't yeah
i just loved it i thought tom cruise is
brilliant i don't i can't think of
another actor who could play that
partner
like no like old-school movie star
yeah i don't really get now that could
play maverick you know yeah just it was
just brilliant
an unabashed matinee idol he's like not
only am i not only am i doing a sequel
to a film that really put me on the map
when i was in my early 20s but now i'm
so big and i'm so rash and out there
that i'm gonna call the sequel me it's
top gun me the whole thing the cameras
are pointing directly at me now get some
of me into your system now who's driving
the queen
me
who's everybody talking about
me
if it's a beautiful woman who is she in
love with
me
and yes
i loved it i loved it i loved it too now
i'm going to say something controversial
not only controversial but so
controversial that when i
uh put forward this point to you you
just ignored it you cut you flat ignored
it you didn't even respond to it
controversial
the controversial comment from me
is
love top gun maverick
still prefer the original is that why
you've grown a goose mustache it is a
ghost moustache well the ghost mustache
is very trendy right now because i mean
obviously anthony edwards did it in the
original and then you've got miles
teller doing it i think the the
moustache is going to make a comeback
into the hot hot summer months i think
it's going to be mustache time i might
grow one
do yeah you couldn't grow one right now
for your job right no
but it's almost finished and i've never
i've never had a moustache i'll grow on
you you had an amazing beard when you
played banquo but i'd love to see it
with a moustache you didn't explain to
the audience why you couldn't make the
interview so explain that and then we'll
bring on terry
i'd love to explain that tom
but i think it was just as simple as
terry was coming in we thought that i
could do it
harry
terry
eric
terry
it's terry pankas not perry tankhurst
terry
hold on if this is johnny
terry
sorry john
[Laughter]
i think i said perry at the start
remember you didn't you said you said
terry pinkhurst at the start and i
didn't correct you it's terry pankert
we're keeping all this in john make a
note we're keeping all this in we're not
trying to offend terry we're just trying
to uh make people realize how wrong
billy can get names so well but i never
met terry
and then
john has that
john did actually send me the correct
name um and i i have written it down
incorrectly
yeah that's a shame he really thanks
terry
whose call sign was spanky because
obviously panky
oh that's a shame yeah what's that say
well that says the entomologist
unfortunately
come on
john keep it all in it's gold
anyway you were on set it's basically
what you're trying to say right you're
at work
yeah yeah so sadly we were hoping that
um i was i was going to uh finish in
time to be able to come over and and
speak to terry but
uh as things went i couldn't i couldn't
get i couldn't get offset
so um
you're very kindly dom says let me do
the heavy lifting here i don't want you
to worry because i asked him all the
questions that i think you could you
would ask which is you know what does it
feel like to have all those g forces on
you uh what does it feel like to eject
out of a plane do you have does anyone
ever pull the hit the brakes and fly
right by i asked all of those classic
questions so why don't we bring on terry
right now
so ladies and gentlemen we are joined
now by
terry pankhurst who looks like he wrote
this bio and i was just reading it and
it's fantastic so before i ask you a ton
of uh crazy fighter jet uh questions
terry i'm just gonna read your bio
because it's it's fascinating
um
grew up on a farm in irondale missouri
graduated high school in 1988 in college
in december 91 with a degree in aviation
tech
and then you put here mostly aircraft
mechanical stuff uh wanted to be a
commercial pilot but with a terrible
market for commercial aviation after the
first go-for chances of that were nearly
non-existent so joined the uh try to
store the air force or naval aviation
navy came through was sworn in and
checked into aviation officer candidate
school 1992
after five months of marine drill
instructors and loads of pt physical
training graduated got married headed to
primary flight training at corpus
christi in texas after primary selected
jets and headed to kingsville texas for
intermediate and advanced strike
training received my wings of gold april
95
headed to san diego california for
training in the s
3b viking
damn flew the viking for nearly four
years on many deployments to faraway
places in february 2000 went to training
command to teach the next generation of
naval aviators literally maverick uh
taught on the t45 goshawk for the next
12 years after retiring in may 2012
taught in the t45 simulator for several
years and have a t45 maintenance test
pilot for over eighty uh eight years now
two daughters from your late wife sorry
to hear that
um
two step daughters three grandchild uh
grandchildren still play video games
think that jokes are a necessary second
language and then you're right here at
the bottom there's so much more i've
probably gone on too long let me know if
you need anything else it was perfect
terry it was perfect
thank you sir man
what a life now
it seems from your bio here that you you
are now currently retired from the navy
or not are you still working i am
retired from the navy as of uh may 2012
but i fly as a civilian contract pilot
so i work for vertex aerospace they
maintain maintain the aircraft when they
do work on them i take them out and test
flying to make sure they actually are
fixed and if they are i sign them off
and put them back in service
wow so your test pi test flying planes
to make sure that everything's okay
after they at one point were not okay so
you're literally the guinea pig to see
if things are working again
i never thought of it that way but i
guess so
so they kind of say hey terry yeah it's
fine you can go up but just in case if
things do go bad we've got the right men
here that's the idea that you you could
troubleshoot in the air
they do good work and um i've not had to
troubleshoot too much very often when
you fly commercially do you tell people
as you're getting on that you're also a
pilot just in case something happens or
do you keep that to yourself
no i i don't do that but uh it'd be a
little bit uh i guess arrogant right
i did fly briefly in a commuter airline
flying embryo 145 so those little
commuter jets the one that has one set
of uh seats on one side and two on the
other yeah and i did that for a few
months before i realized that this
wasn't my life uh so well just was it a
little monotonous backwards and forwards
what what did you not like about that
yeah it's uh it's driving the bus you do
a lot of uh or spend a lot of time
pre-flighting putting stuff into the
flight computer and uh
monitoring the autopilot right that's
just not something i really got behind
him but just to confirm terry if you
were on a plane and both the pilots had
the chicken and you had the shrimp and
the chicken the chicken
yeah they they could you you could put
your hand up and say well i can fly this
plane and land it you could do that with
with any plane out there i could
probably figure it out love that i want
to be on planes with you for the
foreseeable future
fresh from san diego california comes
the only sunglasses brand i'm ever going
to wear again i'm talking about blenders
i wear and you're going to be just as
hooked when you see just how cool these
shades are i have an amazing pair of
sunglasses i keep it in my car they help
me from getting too much sun around my
eyes when i've got my window down people
go hey cool guy what's your name and i
said shut your face i'm wearing
sunglasses
chase fisher started blenders by selling
his beachy shades out of a backpack
while doubling as a surf instructor on
pacific beach his goal was to create
adventurous mid-priced eyewear option
with the same cool factor as the leading
styles and unlike expensive big brand
shades that you probably lost or smashed
at the beach blenders are actually
affordable
so you're not going to cry as much when
the inevitable happens
billy does break a lot of sunglasses
blenders team of in-house designers are
constantly coming out with new styles
from orange polarized wraparounds to
tortoise shell frames with purple lenses
to classic gold arms on black lenses and
it's not just sunglasses blenders has
prescription glasses readers and blue
lights as well as snow collection with
goggles and accessories live life in
forward motion with blenders today to
score 15 off your blender's purchase
visit blenderseyeware.com
and enter the promo code onion vip
that's
blenderseyewear.com code onion vip
for 15 off
ren is a startup that's making it easy
for everyone to make a meaningful
difference in the climate crisis right
now they're focused on monthly
subscriptions where you can calculate
your carbon footprint then offset it by
supporting awesome climate projects to
plant trees protect rainforest and
remove co2 from the sky their goal is to
unlock the collective action of millions
of individuals to drive the systemic
change needed to end the climate crisis
so dom and i have been talking about
this
for quite a few years now and we've done
lots of stuff over the years to try and
help offset our carbon footprint and i
know we have planted a lot a lot of
trees especially in scotland but all
over
and been involved lots of different
companies and ren
really make it easy and simple which is
a great thing to help you offset your
carbon footprint ren is a website where
you can calculate your personal carbon
footprint based on your lifestyle then
offset it by funding projects that plant
trees protect rainforests and sequester
co2 and more signing up for rent is an
easy way to do something meaningful
about the climate crisis wren practices
hyper transparency once you sign up to
make a monthly contribution to offset
your carbon footprint you'll receive
monthly updates about the tree planting
rainforest protection and carbon removal
projects you're funding you can even see
the exact coordinates of the trees
you've planted fantastic it's going to
take all of us to end the climate crisis
do your part today by signing up for
rent go to ren dot co forward slash
onion sign up and they'll plant 10 extra
trees in your name that's w-r-e-n-dot
c-o-slash onion start making a
difference thank you ren
well terry what we do like to do on
these uh shows is ask people kind of
their their origin story because who
knows maybe there is a young girl or a
young boy out there that would love to
be um doing the job that you do so we'd
love to kind of take that back and and
find out where that came from so you
grew up on a farm in missouri were you
fascinated with with planes from a young
age
very young age in fact
i would have to say where it really
sparked in me was i don't know if you
are familiar with a show
starring robert conrad back in the late
70s called uh baba black sheep or black
sheep squadron no i do not know that
show so tell me about that show oh
i'm dating myself
uh and they flew the f4u corsair and
that's my favorite plane in the entire
universe right there uh but it was a
uh story following the exploits of pappy
bowington and the black sheep squadron
of course highly fictionalized
but
they went on missions every week they
had their standard enemies and stuff and
they flew the corsair and
did all kinds of cool stuff and i just
fell in love with uh aviation right then
especially that particular airplane
right so so how quickly
how old are you when you watch that show
and how quickly did you start to put
things into place to think i want to be
a pilot uh probably about the time i was
12 or so i really started to feel that i
wanted to start pushing that way i
started feeling the need to
or the urgency to get started along that
path so
i
my mom and dad knew this they took me to
a local airport and
showed me the airplanes got to talk to
some of the old pilots and stuff
and
basically they told me how much it would
cost to get your private pilot's license
in the early 80s that was about
i don't know probably fifteen hundred
dollars or so
my mom and dad thought that would
discourage a 12-year-old but what it did
is it gave me a goal yeah so i started
uh you know mowing lawns and doing all
kinds of other chores and
raised
almost all of that money
fast forward to 1987
early 87
and i had money amassed and i wanted to
to really go ahead and give it a try so
we went back to the airport
and uh
i was going to sign up for lessons and
stuff and
an older gentleman in the corner pulled
me to the side my mom and dad as well
and said the best way to do this if you
want to do it as a group as a family is
to buy yourself
and one of the older airplanes and
everyone get their license and if you
don't want to keep the airplane sell it
at the end because airplanes have a
tendency to keep their value if you take
care of them you can sell them for as
much or more than you bought them for
so believe it or not my
uh my parents got on board with that and
we ended up buying a plane uh an old 62
uh cessna 172. so that's like a little
kind of five c or seven seater type
plane how many people can see it's only
four okay it's a very simple airplane a
fixed pitch prop fixed gear the whole
bit right so you buy the plane and then
then you're looking for someone to teach
you how to how to fly that plane the
entire family your mom dad and yourself
uh yes sir we got a uh an uh older
instructor been around for a good while
but uh
knew all the all the tricks i guess and
we paid him uh by the hour to
uh teach us in that airplane uh i got my
license in about five months mom and dad
took a little bit longer but we all
three ended up getting a private license
wow and how old were we where you get
were you sorry when you got your license
you just graduated in high school is
that right oh uh 17. so and that's
that's the youngest that you can get it
it's 16 17 times uh
17 for the license you can solo when
you're 16 though wow
so you get you
you get your pilot's license and you
graduate from high school and then what
is the what is your path and is that the
normal path that most people are taking
to be a pilot uh
no that's probably not really the normal
path um
speaking from the military side most
people show up to primary training with
no previous experience um
so i was a little bit of an anomaly
there yeah if you're going commercial
aviation uh straight to the airlines
then yeah that's probably how you do you
get your private license work your way
up through your ratings become an
instructor yourself in small planes
build your hours and then finally uh get
picked up when you have enough at uh
oh some small twin engine uh outfit
maybe and then
from there you'd go to the commuter
airlines and from there you go to the uh
to the majors so you came in to
the navy already as a pilot which most
people would have to have that
rudimentary training is that correct
right and it was very helpful helpful
through primary training by the time you
get to jets it really is a different
world though um so it really doesn't buy
you much of anything there yeah um so
much of that training is procedural in
uh uh instrument uh flight which i
didn't have a whole lot of
and uh that pretty much leveled the
playing field from intermediate and
advanced yeah i'm sure and then i'm
reading here it says you wrote that you
had five months of marine drill
instructors and lots of physical
training so let's just let's just go
into that a little bit this is this is
the kind of model where they're trying
as hard as they can to see
if you will be able to
take orders what your what your mental
strength is like alongside your physical
strength but could you just talk us
flesh fleshed out a little bit what
that's about i'll do my best um
there is a movie with uh richard gere
from way back called an officer and a
gentleman yeah that is supposed to be
aocs
and uh
that's fairly close i suppose but it's
not quite as uh
loose i guess as that movie might have
been plus it doesn't take place in
washington state at that time aocs was
in pensacola florida right
the physical part of that's probably
pretty close i think at one point i was
averaging running anywhere from eight to
nine and a half uh miles a day from
different stuff
uh there's also academics involved and
yes the drill instructors
uh
would treat you to say at least very
poorly to make sure you really want this
you gotta remember you've got guys with
four-year uh college degrees and if they
can survive this program they're going
to get commissioned and they're going to
go to flight school they need to know
that it's really worth
that to you it's like
i had to describe to me as holding on to
the tailgate of a truck while they're
trying to stomp your fingers and make
you let go
um yeah i want to say my class started
with 27 and we finished with 12. that
was about the average right okay so
they're generally looking to cut it in
half at the lease type thing
um
and it's as much as a mental game as it
is a physical game right i mean
throughout the day you're obviously
doing a lot of physical stuff but
absolutely right but really the
instructors are trying to say they're
trying to see
can they handle
the mental torture that we're putting on
top of the physical torture
yes very much so very much i mean i
remember richard gearing an officer and
a gentleman just constantly saying over
and over again that he wasn't going to
quit that's all they're trying to make
you do is quit right they're like go
ring the bell go quick it's fine you can
have a hot meal and you know sleep in a
nice bed for however long you want and
because the enemy the quote-unquote
enemy they're gonna be way crueler than
the drill instructors that's what
they're trying to drill into you right
right exactly okay so you do the
physical training is is it is it a is it
a failed pass type thing or is it just
the people that get to the end pass uh
well i'd say fail pass i mean if you
can't do the runs you can drop out at
that time you could drop out of three
runs and over a four month period that's
a lot of runs
uh and if you dropped out of more than
that then you would go on probation if
you dropped out again you're probably
out
so yeah it was pretty um
uh pretty strict okay so you passed that
and then from there
what what happens after
the five months with the marine drill
instructors
oh then they got a primary training and
there's two places for that in the navy
one is uh
near pensacola florida whiting field and
the other is corpus christi texas uh nes
corpus um there at that time we would go
fly a plane called the t-34 uh mentor
and nowadays it's the t6 texan 2
and then depending on how you do out of
that program how your grades are and
what's available needs of the navy you
you put a dream sheet in as to what you
want to go fly whether it's helicopters
or a large wing aircraft or
what they call strike which is anything
that goes on board the carrier
and depending on your grades needs the
navy and availability you get what you
can right so i selected one or i
selected jets kingsville and was able to
go down there for uh my intermediate and
advanced training so that's that's
intermittent and advanced fighter jet
training yeah right uh if you want to be
more specific you'd call it strike
training because you also include in
that um non-fighter aircraft i flew the
s3 viking which is not a fighter
aircraft it is a surface control
aircraft i i would hunt uh surface ships
and submarines um and of course the e2
hawkeye you're probably familiar with
has the large spinning dome on top
and then of course nowadays it's pretty
much it's some flavor of hornet uh or uh
the f-35 charlie
and
generally
is there is there usually
a kind of
a thing that the best people in the
class all want to do like did the best
generally or want to be kind of at the
sharper edge of the
of the weapon kind of doing the most
stuff yeah yeah uh some people have
their own specific uh
uh desire some people maybe if they
don't want quite as dynamic a flying
might try to go
uh well in my day s3 vikings or uh e2
hawkeyes i did want to fly a hornet or
tomcat but didn't quite have the grades
compared to the other guys i finished
with so i ended up in the s3s which
turned out to be a great deal yeah but
no i'd be lying if i said i um chose
that first
so once again it comes down to your
grades right and to be flying the
tomcats you you need you need to be like
the best in the country type thing
uh the tomcat believe it or not um you
had to be good at landing on the ship
it's one of the harder ones to bring
aboard
the second one was actually one called
the ea6b prowler that one was equally as
hard so if you had really good boat
grades if everything else is really good
you might find yourself in a ea 6b
prowler because of that
so kind of a double-edged sword doing
good at the boat the first time that's
the classic kind of landing on the
aircraft carrier and and it has the
little bungee cord that kind of grabs
all of the plastic oh yes that's still
that still happens to this day that's
not that's not just a top gun cheesy
thing oh that is absolutely real um and
uh we send in fact we have kids going to
the boat this week
so the g's
the g-forces on just landing a plane
like that because you're coming in
relatively fast and then it's grabbing
hold of you very quickly and bringing
you to a halt very quickly what's the
g's in the landing process do you know
i'm not sure exactly what the g's are my
guess would be probably only about uh
four if i had to put a number to it but
you're going from 150 mile per hour
roughly to zero in about
i don't know three four seconds yeah
that's that's a lot i mean you know most
people are not ever experiencing that
unless they're in unless they've done
something really wrong with their car
and and they're in a fast car you know
uh good point
well let's let's talk about life on an
aircraft carrier if you're
if you're stationed out on an aircraft
carrier um
as a pilot how much time are you
generally actually out on that ship okay
every aircraft carrier has a sign to it
an air wing and the air wing is
comprised of several different squadrons
usually located at different places in
the country most of our our hornet
squadrons are divided between uh
uh california lamar and oceana in
virginia and our growlers which uh are
the electronic warfare hornets are up in
washington state
and uh various other places for some of
the other aircraft anyway the air wing
is put together by squadrons from each
of these locations and they come
together at the beginning of what we
call the workup cycle and that usually
begins up in fallon nevada which by the
way is where top gun is actually located
these days
it used to be miramar but for 20
something years it's been fallon nevada
i can't believe tom cruise got something
wrong that's outrageous well actually
they they covered it pretty well in the
movie because he wasn't going to top gun
he was going to meet top gun graduates
at north island which is where i was
stationed in s3s for a while that is
true we'll get into top gun at some
point don't worry but please go
all right
um
anyway so the uh airwing gets together
and they start doing the rudimentary
stuff that makes them become a team
everything from air-to-air refueling to
going on uh
simple missions progressively harder
missions until the entire air wing works
together like a you know well-oiled
machine
then they take this well-oiled machine
and they take it to the carrier for a
work-up cycle
usually off the coast of um well maybe
around puerto rico or off the coast of
carolina or something like that and
that's usually four or five weeks long
where once again you start out with
basic you know carrier operations you
know get back to the basics of landing
on the ship and taking off and going
through those cycles
and then you start introducing more and
more uh simulated war games um
then you come back off the ship for a
little while longer ship goes through
some final preparations as does the air
wing get together for one more of those
exercises usually three or four weeks
long and then you are
certified by navair i think to actually
go on cruise at that point you're you're
fully up and ready if you will right
then you go on cruise usually for six to
seven months uh if there's isn't any
trouble in the world
and uh then you come home and go on some
downtime and then you start the whole
cycle again after a few months so in
those times when you're when you're away
for six or seven months and and there
isn't any you know uh
real major trouble
you're going out on exercises at that
point you're replicating trouble is that
right uh pretty much yeah the uh
fighters will go high and do a cap
missions they'll will often play with uh
other foreign powers the french like to
play with us a lot uh so the brits
so we'll do war games with each other
just to you know keep each other sharp
um flying s3s my job was to paint a
picture of every surface ship out there
and assess their threat and if necessary
prosecute though that in the
mediterranean where i did my cruises
that wasn't really all
uh needed that much the closest i came
to firing on a ship was uh during kosovo
in 99 when milosevic if you might
remember that whole thing uh he left his
navy in port we basically told him if he
came out of port you know we would take
him out and he never even fired up the
boilers so and did he have a large navy
in comparison to what you guys were
threatening him with oh not even close
not not really
it would just be posturing if he came
out i mean very often it does seem to be
that in in modern day warfare is a lot
of posturing right it's like well look
have a look at what we've got we're
massive and have a look at what you've
got you're not that big let's just have
a nice compromise here
yeah political stuff and roe rules of
engagement play a lot in that and uh
it's not uncommon for the little guy if
you want to call it that to uh
rattle their sabers as the term goes
right next to the mark that we've drawn
um just to show that they to the world
that they
quote unquote stood up to the big guy
right right i was filming in ukraine
about eight or nine years ago we were in
the crimea region which is obviously
southern ukraine
and uh in a few of the restaurants that
we had eaten at that were on
the kind of coastline harbor there the
people working in the restaurants would
point out oh there was a russian
submarine kind of coming up to the
surface over there a few weeks ago and
over there a few weeks ago and again
it's just a way of kind of saying hey
we're just letting you guys know we're
here not gonna do anything but we are
here and you know just deal with it
right
yeah crazy um
all right well let's talk top gun
because you
graduated you graduated high school in
1988 i believe the original top gun came
out in 1987.
so 86 86 so terry you're you're right in
it you're what are you 13 14 when top
gun came out something like that uh 16.
oh man come on
old guy
so that must have been it that must have
been a crazy film for you i just
recently saw
so i had friends come up to stay with me
uh this
weekend friday night we watched what
we're now calling og original gangster
top gun and then we watched the new top
gun oh saturday morning at the cinema um
but
i mean
similar to the karate kid because when i
was a kid
i joined a karate class and and did it
for you know kind of a year or two and
the instructors said every time the
karate kid is on the tv we get 50 extra
people in our classes these top gun
films must be so
influential in your particular field of
work does it get in any way
annoying where people are like oh so
who's your ice man and who's your
maverick well there's a lot of
misconceptions
that top gun has kind of brought about
for the navy but i want to say both
movies are fantastic
uh most naval aviators really love them
but
you have to leave reality at the door
but they're both fantastic movies i
especially this last one i was i was
pretty blown away by what tom cruise
referred to as a love letter to aviation
yeah he was right yeah it's beautiful
the way they the way they frame the
aircraft the way the aircraft are taking
off the way they perform in these
skirmishes even even every level of
transport the way he rides motorcycles
the way he drives car it is it is a real
love letter i had watched some youtube
kind of um
breaking some of these myths about
original top gun and the new top gun and
this pilot had said
you know the the way that they coined
the term bogey is completely incorrect
because a bogey is essentially an
unidentified aircraft we don't know
where they're from right but as soon as
they're identified they are they are now
no longer a bogey they're something else
is that correct a bandit a bandit right
okay
so i think maybe they say banned it in
the in this recent film but in the
previous one everything's a bogey and
that's that's not right right
right well they had a several things in
the first one that
you kind of had to roll your eyes at and
one of the biggest ones that always
bothered me when
when maverick is fighting jester and
jester is quote unquote you know diving
below the hard deck to get away yeah the
hard deck is the simulated ground
jester flew into the ground
and mav yeah and maverick follows him so
maverick commits suicide essentially
come on as far as
as far as the engagement is concerned
that's exactly what happened okay yeah
that's not cool and that would have been
maverick's kill had he just not gone
below the deck himself tom cruise
messing it up again uh the other thing
the other thing in the first um top gun
that doesn't make any sense i mean first
of all the inverted um you know giving
the bird to the enemy thing is just is
just so unsafe that you would
immediately be court-martialed and never
work again but he's using uh he's using
a polaroid camera with a flash so the
glare from his screen would not yeah it
would not show up the enemy
um yeah i i
i want to ask you this because i've
never had the opportunity to ask someone
with your level of qualifications the
the way that goose unfortunately passes
away in the original top gun spoiler
alert if you've not seen it but it is
30 years ago who hasn't is could that be
an accurate way that a pilot might
succumb to
serious injury or death well it would
take a mechanical malfunction now the
movie kind of makes you think that
somehow he did something wrong because
maverick says watch the canopy well
there's no control over that it's
completely automated when you pull that
handle that canopy flies first and then
within less than uh i think 1.5 seconds
both seats are out of the jet
so goose had no control over that so
saying watch the canopy doesn't mean
anything yeah it's kind of a hero thing
for tom cruise's character to say but
yeah he doesn't there would there would
be no examples previously of people
having watched the canopy had stayed
safe or not watched it and died yeah
right it'd have to be a mechanical
malfunction of some kind right how often
throughout a average calendar year would
you guess
pilots are jettisoning their planes
it's not common right um no it's it's
not common at all um if you ever look at
you can look this up online at the
mishap rate in the navy you'll see a
geometric curve downward uh
to
back in the 50s they were losing a plane
almost every day somewhere in the navy
to the point now where we probably lose
knock on wood uh 20 or so maybe in a
year right
so
i wouldn't uh
the human factor that's in there is
usually
unfortunately what happens um either
someone didn't react quick enough or
they did something that they might or
they shouldn't have right but every once
in awhile you do have catastrophic you
know failures and uh i did like in top
gun maverick where they had the bird
strike that actually happens fairly
often yeah happens that happens on
commercial jets as well right commercial
planes
it does yeah um
i've hit a few birds fortunately nothing
catastrophic goshawk only has one engine
so if it went down the intake it's
probably toast yeah wow that's crazy now
if you're a pilot that has found
yourself in a position where you have
ejected from a plane twice is that kind
of the end of your career
there actually is a limitation but it's
more medical than anything else when you
eject from the aircraft
all joking aside you actually lose maybe
a half inch on your height because it
compresses your spine so bad
um so there are probably limitations
on how many injections you could you can
have and still be allowed to fly
ejection seat aircraft wow so the the
average fighter pilot coming towards the
end of their career are they exhibiting
relatively similar
injuries do you have do you have
problems with your spines your problems
with your neck or does g-force bring in
any kind of common injuries
g-force can
when you're in control of the aircraft
and you pull heavy g's you're ready for
it you're in a good position for it when
you're teaching students and they
suddenly decide to pull without really
telling you or you're not or at some
unexpected point it can catch you if
you're looking slightly off to the side
it can tweak your neck pretty bad right
um
most guys who teach uh acm air combat
maneuvering in the aircraft or bfm as we
call it now basic fighter maneuvers
um
two or three years if you can go that
whole time without having a real neck
injury you're probably doing good
wow um and in that fighter training
stuff that goes up with real planes in
the sky
would it be fair to say that what we're
seeing in both of these top gun films is
way closer than it would be in the
exercises that you guys do because if
you clip a wing you can kill someone
easily right
well we fly very close to each other now
when he when maverick flies between the
formation yeah uh and surprises them
okay yeah that's that's
it's cavaliers
imagine that happening
yeah it's really cool yeah you got to
give it that but no you really wouldn't
want to do something like that because
if anyone
moves at the last second you're going to
take everyone with you right i mean it
is quite maverick it's quite a maverick
move and it's a it is you know he and
part of me says that is so cool he's
living living up to go with that my
friends and i on friday night when we
were watching the original one my friend
will and i said because this kind of a
fun exercise the next time you watch the
original top gun watch the original top
gun with a view of objectively trying to
decide whether or not
uh maverick is kind of a dick in the
first film because
he he is objectively kind of addicted i
mean he's he's a nice guy whatever he's
a handsome dude everyone likes him he's
got that you know cocky arrogance but
he's not very nice to his fellow pilots
he puts goose in an extraordinary amount
of danger and threat of being dismissed
like three or four times just because he
wants to like do a flyby and tutors he's
not nice to charlie he's disrespectful
to his instructors you know in the final
exercise where they where they bring him
back and he goes up with ice and
you know he bugs out for a second i
would assume even though he comes back
and quote unquote saves the mission the
fact that he bogged out for a moment
would mean okay thanks but you're done
that's that's your career over
yeah it could be um that's another thing
is really only a hollywood setting
because you know most uh engagements
last
honestly about uh 45 seconds to two
minutes tops so those critical few
seconds where he's off trying to talk to
me goose
uh his wing his you know ice is already
dead right right yeah because he's been
he's being ganged up on that point um
right but i got the same feeling about
his character too because in this
business
the number one thing you have to have
with everyone is trust you have to trust
that they are going to have your back
right right and that's paramount so yes
you're absolutely right on that call
yeah um now the thing about locking on
and tone and all this kind of stuff so
when you're locking on that's that's
trying to get the missile that you're
carrying underneath your plane to
tell you that if you were to fire it at
this point there's a very strong chance
that it would lock on to the plane
that's in front of it correct right most
missile missiles have what's called
initial homing where you lock it and
tell it where to go and then once it
gets close enough to its target
depending on what type of a sensoring uh
unit it's using whether it's heat or
whatever then it takes in goes on what's
called terminal homing where it's taking
care of it itself um
and yes the
they had a much better heads-up display
uh for the second movie than the first
one the first one was obviously very 80s
looking yeah um
but the premise is is relatively um
solid on that now even if the parent
didn't and that that
tone that maverick and goose or whomever
else here in their cockpit is that tone
also heard by the enemy
that they've been locked onto no no it's
it's not they kind of make it seem like
it is because when it starts buzzing
they go to the other cockpit
um now what they are gonna hear in their
cockpit is we have these things uh
what's called raw gear which is a
basically warning when something has
locked on to you it's not like a fuzz
buster you know in your car yeah um so
their tone may not be the same one but
yes they would probably know that they
were locked on to they would hear
something okay cool now and and what
about the science of
or the physics maybe of um
hitting the blades hitting the brakes
and flying right by so i was saying to
my friend will over the weekend i was
like i'm confused he pulls he pushes
forward and pulls back to me that feels
like he wouldn't go up and backwards but
is that correct or not
so i'm at the original top gun when he
does the original fly right by
thanksgiving yeah yeah he had the
throttles backwards on that he would
have pulled him back popped his speed
brakes
to slow down as rapidly as possible and
pull directly up to also create more
parasite drag putting it forward yeah so
in an original top gun he if he was
doing it right he would pull back with
both hands and then push forward with
his feet is that right well the feet are
your rudder so pushing forward wouldn't
do anything
good one
foot or the other is going to move your
rudder left to right so yeah feet would
have nothing to do with it but pulling
the throttle back to idle and pulling
the stick up to do
they refer to it kind of as a cobra
maneuver if you will at least at the
beginning of it yeah yeah and it would
allow the other craft to fly right by
unless they
copied them but i guess you're supposed
to understand he did it so quickly they
couldn't respond yeah or if they were
too close and instead of just flying
right by they just smash right into it
right exactly they had to reflexively
miss them in this in the second top gun
film he he gets it more accurate is that
right the way that he does the flyby he
does um
the first film one of the other kind of
uh comical parts of the fighting that
they did is you would have one aircraft
in front of the other
the one in front would do an aileron
roll well that's real pretty thanks and
shoot him right no it doesn't do
anything
but it looks good yeah it's like that
was pretty you know thank you yeah
exactly um uh but the real
acm or uh fighting dog fighting is like
a knife fight in a closet you're trying
to get in there as fast as you can
behind the other guy any way it takes
and to do that you have to fight your
jet to the best possible ability
in the t45 for instance you have to stay
right in the neighborhood of best
cornering speed which i believe is
around 300 knots for the goshawk if you
can maintain that speed and energy and
turn a tight circle and out perform the
other t45 you'll eventually end up on
their tail you shoot them right that
it does not look as good you know as
aileron rolls and whatnot but that's how
it actually goes that's that's the more
accurate way of doing what you're
supposed to do up in the sky yeah right
and i think they alluded to that much
better in this film yeah uh the second
one yeah they seem to
you know seem to do that yeah i mean
look i i'm slightly taking the michael
out of the top gun films i absolutely
love them the original top gun
completely holds up the second one we
had so much fun at the cinema um i loved
so many things about that second film
one of the things that i really liked
was
when
tom cruise's character finds himself
back in the plane that he flew in the
original top gun it does look very dated
doesn't it it looks kind of like ah yeah
and even goose's son it's like oh look
at this old dinosaur or what am i
supposed to do with this but clearly
technology moves on so fast and you must
have an acute understanding of just how
fast technology moves on because in the
navy you're at that finer point of
technology aren't you
actually to be honest uh depends on what
part of the navy you're talking if
you're at the tip of the spear super
hornets f-35 charlie's especially yeah
you probably have close to the latest
and greatest in the old goshawk um and i
even flew an older version of the
goshawk that i'm flying now technology
currently is probably about 30 years old
probably a lot one hornet i guess would
be the closest thing to what we
currently have right because that's all
you need in the training command
but the closer you get to the tip of the
spear yeah the better the equipment's
going to be
now you were an instructor is that
correct i'm reading here right um i had
an interesting career that way
i flew the s3 of the fleet went to the
training command in kingsville texas in
2000 february and started teaching in
the t-45 alpha
and after i was planning on doing a
hornet transition because the s3 viking
was going away in just a few more years
well they had to extend the s3 vikings
uh service because the super hornets
weren't being built fast enough to take
over our role as an indigenous
air-to-air refueling tanker uh
in time so they were going to send us
back the fleet to do nothing but pretty
much tanking missions
back to back-to-back cruises and i was
like i don't really want to do that
right so
fortunately at the time though they came
up with a new program that they now call
fts full-time support where i became a
reservist but a full-time reservist so i
act the same as an active duty guy but
my whole world just became the training
command so for the next uh
you know for a total of 12 years i
taught in the t45 uh we have four
advanced strike squadrons and i ended up
teaching in all four of them and that is
that is literally you know for for the
layman including myself at home that
that is taking pilots up in the sky and
and
putting them through drills yes sir
yeah they've just come from primary from
t6s or t34s in the old days and we teach
them the intermediate advanced syllabus
everything from uh
familiarization advanced instruments uh
formation flying tactical formation uh
air combat maneuvering we used to teach
air to air gunnery um
and uh
dropping bombs weapons and finally
culminating with landing aboard the
carrier for the first time right wow
which i'm sure is extremely scary now to
to touch upon the original uh top gun
for a second in
at the start of that film we witnessed a
pilot cougar essentially going through a
kind of anxiety attack in the sky
because i think he's
does his plane fly through a jet wash is
that is that an actual terminal no he's
simply he gets the guy behind him he
gets one of those f5 yeah the f5 freedom
fighter that's supposed to be a mig-28
gets behind him he gets tone he knows
he's locked up and that causes him to
have some type of a breakdown he looks
at a picture of his wife and child i
guess right hopefully it's his wife and
child not just some woman and a kid
came with the wallet you know you never
know but now what i was going to ask you
in regards to that was in in your time
instructing were you ever in a situation
with a student where you had to talk
them down from you know going through an
amount of anxiety that stopped them from
doing their job uh nothing like that
i've had a student uh do what's called
g-lock before which is you know totally
not their fault they just weren't
prepared for enough g's and they caused
them to momentarily uh uh blank out i
took the controls they recovered then we
sent that guy off to what they call the
centrifuge which is that thing you've
seen on movies before where they spin
you around to your eyeballs come out
yeah um he and he came back good to go
he learned his g tolerance limits and
how to affect him better so you were in
that you were in the cockpit behind the
guy when he passed out is that correct
yes sir yeah and the instructor
obviously you're you're both facing the
same direction so the only reason why
you knew that he had passed out was
because the the the controls were not
being used yeah yeah pretty much wow
um for you obviously you're conscious so
it's not too scary but when he came back
to consciousness was he was he freaked
out
yeah there are several moments of uh
disorientation you don't even know where
you are or what's going on so when that
happens and i've only only had to do
that once uh just started talking to him
just saying hey how are you feeling
right what what's your name and ask some
basic questions they come back pretty
fast right
which leads me on to my question about
g-force um obviously we hear about
g-force a lot
in these aviation films and uh
this is this is the amount of gravity
force pushing itself on the human body
is that correct and the mind i guess
exactly uh one g is what you're feeling
right now yeah two g's would be if you
just doubled your weight and three g's
if you triple your weight and so forth
okay so so it literally makes you double
as heavy triple heavy quadruple heavy
and and right exactly and suddenly going
from being your normal weight to nine
times heavier will do something to the
way that your blood moves in your body
isn't it yeah it sucks it right out of
your head um so sucks it from your head
to your feet is that right exactly it
follows gravity so we wear g-suits or
speed jeans if you want to call them
that and that squeezes our legs and
torso to try to slow that effect there's
also maneuvers you can do where you
basically tighten everything you've got
muscle wise
from the waist on down or really from
the chest on down to try to delay that
blood leaving your brain
so the so the average let's let's say
for the sake of argument the average
passenger
in a long-haul flight you're taking off
from los angeles in your life and you're
landing in sydney are they feeling are
they having any experience of g-force
and if so what would that be
probably very little i'd say commercial
airlines the most you're probably going
to experience unless something's going a
little bit wrong would be maybe two g's
okay
now as as you start to ramp that up with
your students and with you in your job
you're now pushing into seven eight nine
ten g's is that something that you can
deal with uh the gas hawk is limited to
7.3 uh the hornet as they did point out
in uh the the newer maverick movie i'm
glad they acknowledged that when he
pulled those uh nine and a half 10 g's
or whatever simulating pulling out of
that canyon that he may have trashed
that hornet um i i did appreciate that
they pointed out so the plane would
literally just break apart if you're in
a goshawk and you find yourself you know
trying to pull eight g's the the plane
would just start to break apart is that
correct
well it probably wouldn't break apart
then you could probably abuse it very
badly but you would have damage around
the airplane you'd have stress points
that
so yeah the plane would have to be
uh and you know torn way down inspected
every part of it they'd have to what's
called magnafluxing the the metal to see
if it was uh strained and so forth it
would almost be like having to tear down
and rebuild the whole airplane right so
that that pilot's in trouble if they do
that
yes yeah that would be bad okay um
classically in these top gun films
there's a there's a huge amount of
competition certainly in the first film
it's quite quite mean-spirited
competition at times in the second film
there seems to be a little bit more
camaraderie this this top gun
competition if you will still continues
to happen every year from from your
experience is it a little bit more kind
of
a group of people supporting each other
than a group of people in competition
it's more people supporting each other
especially at this particular level and
in the fleet
this is going to sound kind of odd but
the um highest honors if you will or
marks on a fitness report which is what
really matters for your next set of
orders
uh doesn't often come down in any way to
flight ability um it not who has the
every landing you make on the ship they
have what's called a greenie board in
your ready room every landing you make
goes on that board for everyone to see
so if you're the lowest everybody knows
it you're the highest everyone knows it
but that's more just of a pride but when
it but when it comes to advancement um
fit reps usually have absolutely nothing
to do with that it has to do with who
does their their jobs best who's gotten
the quals fast enough or faster than the
others and
you know things like that but the flying
itself really does not weigh in uh like
top gun would make you think that it
does right and i'm sure obviously
with people living in such close
quarters with each other not only going
through the training but being on an
aircraft carrier what what is also
extremely important is your ability to
stay good humid and and not have a short
fuse and things like that right
it's not that bad going on cruise is
like going uh to summer camp with your
best friends it's just the only thing
that stinks is being away from your
family and friends yeah yeah now on an
aircraft car i've never been on an
aircraft carrier i've been lucky enough
to be on a submarine that was obviously
at the surface when i was in hawaii
which was which was a fascinating
experience yeah the confinement of that
at pearl harbor i was i was absolutely
fascinated by that but on an aircraft
carrier
um what are the more surprising things
that you guys have that we might not
know about is there is there a bar
is there a screening room is there a
pool table
there is not a bar there
for a screening room uh not per se there
are conference rooms and briefing rooms
and stuff like that
uh
it's kind of funny that you should say
that because during vietnam when a lot
of our guys were captured the
vietnamese had this idea that the
carrier had all kinds of stuff on there
including
animals we must have animals to keep
food out there for us right so you know
where do you keep the cows where do you
keep objections
and
one of the uh one of the guys who was
captured kept telling him no we don't
have it and they kept beating him
because they wouldn't believe it so
finally he's like yeah fine okay we have
uh the bowling alleys here that you know
whatever he just made up
everything he could he was so tired of
them not believing that he just gave
them what they wanted they wrote it all
down
so
misconceptions uh there are about 5 000
people on that aircraft carrier um
and when the air wing comes on board the
the aircraft carrier sinks about 12 more
inches in the water wow um
yeah it's about 85 85 aircraft i think
roughly
um how fast can an aircraft carrier go
when it's when it's going as fast as it
can do you know nuclear carriers can get
uh in excess of 33 knots i think maybe a
little faster i'm not really sure what
their outer limit is but when it's going
that fast the whole thing does shudder a
lot yeah yeah um now you said 5 000
people on a fully working aircraft
carrier right so right within within
those five or six months that you're
there you'll generally get to know most
people certainly by faces right
uh only usually who you work with i
could have told you
uh who any of the deck crew were from
their faces i may not recognize them
with their cranials off and such but i
would know them by looking at them right
and they would know us and of course
everyone has their own reputation
most people as high professionals but
you know a few not so much um so you
always want to behave yourself as best
as possible so you can get to
you know they wouldn't do anything
dangerous but you want to make sure that
you stay on the good side because they
do control your destiny nothing like
being on the front of that carrier in
the pitch black all your lights are off
you cannot see anything but two wands
out in front of you and you are two feet
from going over the side of the deck
um and they're
really watching them and trusting them
to turn you so that you don't do exactly
that yeah um now there's there's
probably a misconception that you know a
lot of these fighter pilots are kind of
uh you know cocky and arrogant and i'm
sure that the top gun films have not
necessarily helped that that much d is
is there kind of is there this kind of
central nucleus of the pilots that are
all kind of like no one no one really
wants to talk to us everyone's a little
bit shy around us type thing no um
and a common misconception is that
they're all egotistical right but truth
be told whenever you do a mission and
you come back training mission or
otherwise
90 of what you're going to talk about is
what you did wrong because that's the
only way you learn from it there's no
point in going over the stuff you did
right if you did it right then that's
great um you have to have a thick skin
in this business if you cannot take
constructive criticism then you are
definitely not going to last very long
also
very important you don't have to be a
self-made martyr but you do need to own
your mistakes if you don't people will
learn this quickly and they will if
you're the guy that always has an excuse
why it wasn't your fault they are never
going to trust you so the balance in
there is just calling it exactly how it
is and learning from your mistakes
owning them right a little bit of
humility i'm sure um
now what's this what's this thing that
goes on in both of these top gun films
where when when one of the planes takes
off from
from the aircraft carrier you have guys
who are obviously you know instructed in
what direction to move their wheels into
stuff and they do like a little dance
move thing they're all kind of like whoa
there you go
you'll sometimes get some eccentric
behavior out of some of the controllers
but for the most part the signals are
standardized and um i think i know which
one you're talking about that might have
been were getting ready to when they had
just launched somebody that was maybe a
little celebratory thing yeah i thought
maybe because they're so close to such a
powerful piece of machinery that is like
hurtling down the runway and then out in
the sky maybe they're just so excited
they're like yay there he
goes it is kind of a rush i stood out on
the on the carrier deck and watched a
few uh launches and uh i was a safety
officer so my job was to be out there
and make sure these people who always do
their jobs are doing it safely i felt
like kind of a hypocrite but yeah that
was my
job i bet it's a rush i'm sure it's a
rush there was actually when i when i
first moved to los angeles i said to my
friend this it doesn't happen anymore
probably for good reason but when i
first moved to los angeles in the back
of these kind of magazines you know gq
and esquire and blah blah blah where the
classified ads were i distinctly
remember there was this thing that said
be a top gun pilot and it was for a day
you go out into i think probably like
the joshua tree or or the palm desert or
somewhere and you take off in a plane
with a pilot obviously and you get the
opportunity to quote unquote lock on
with your friend in a dog fight they're
obviously staying safe and stuff but
you're the person who decides you know
when you're gonna lock onto to your
target um they stopped doing that
probably because it was incredibly
expensive and and maybe unsafe but there
was a point where you could do that i'm
sure you i remember that yeah you you
must have a lot of people in your life
saying well could you take me up in uh
in one of those top gun planes and
you're like no that's not how this works
i wish i could believe me the number of
people i'd love to take yeah um well
i'll let you go terry i do i do want to
ask you one last question because i've
always wondered about this too the call
signs the nicknames is that something
that you choose or is that something
that is attributed to your personality
or is it totally random it is either
something you did that is embarrassing
okay or it is just some often a play off
someone's last names and uh the call
signs in top gun of course are
a little bit fictional only because
they're too kind
so it's usually a little bit of a dis so
your last name is pankhurst and is that
way is that where your call sign spanky
came from because it was spanky yes sir
okay yeah i always think i need to come
up with a good story for that this year
where i end up handcuffed to something
but no
it's nothing special in your time
working in the navy was there someone
with a particular call sign where you
were like damn that's a cool one i wish
i had that
i can tell you the funniest one i ever
saw was on the side of a hornet and uh
this guy's last name um and i apologize
to him if he's watching this but uh his
last name was baltimore was balsitis
right and his call sign was scroton ah
brilliant i love it
i love the humor probably not pc these
days probably couldn't get away with
that but you never know that's okay uh
you got you've got to have a sense of
humor in in all walks of life right um
yes sir well terry it's it's fun uh
fantastic to talk to you fascinating to
talk to you it's brilliant that um we
got a chance to talk to someone who's
had the life that you've led at a time
where
the ma the biggest movie on the planet
is is something that is essentially a
love letter to to the job that you've
done so uh it's been really really
fascinating to talk to you thank you dom
i sure appreciate it
well dom that was fantastic look at you
you you were you were on a roll there
that was i was amazing that interview
you had me at the edge of my seat
yeah thank you um does it make you feel
like you might want to quit your career
and join the uh naval aviators
quite a lot and actually my son when he
went to see top gun maverick he wrote to
me and says yeah that's what i want to
do now
he's going to be a fighter pilot
how's his vision is it 21 21
22 22.
oh good for jack nice one jack well
um
we should say toodle pit to everyone
because um
that fantastic interview with terry was
lovely and weighty and long and we've
ran out of time um it was fantastic well
done terry and well done tom that was
lovely i very much enjoyed that
thank you william um as always if you
guys want to get in touch with us you
can get in touch with us at uh the
french monument cast media.com send us
all your questions send us your riddles
send us your tongue twisters send us
your places where you think lord of the
rings trilogy might benefit from a from
a naughty word here and there send us uh
ideas for items that you want us to eat
from around the world
and if you guys want to look as cool as
tom cruise and top gun maverick wear
some merchandise from the friendship
onion and you can get that at the
friendshiponionpodcast.com
nice and uh we will see you guys
next week see you next week bye
[Music]
all through the night you're shining
bright i'm your oyster baby you're my
pearl